what up space fam goes in here from
anime uproar and wow this is a whole
other level of crazy right here with
this
chapter we see what happens to luffy
after the crazy cliffhanger last chapter
learn more about droid boy kaido and the
list goes on and so make sure to stay
tuned for that
if you do enjoy these chapter reviews
and want to keep them coming channel the
pirate king within and
smash that like button until it's blue
if you haven't make this the video you
subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on all notifications or you will miss
future one piece
videos lastly while you wait for the
next chapter to drop feel free to check
out my growing one piece playlist that
includes videos on all the yonko
warlords
supernova and more link to that is in
the description now without further ado
let's jump into it spoilers
and all this chapter is called a
lifelong
ham actor which suggests kanjuro i won't
lie to you i had to look up
what the ham part actually meant and it
turns out to mean an actor who is overly
theatrical and if that isn't the best
way to describe kanjiro i don't know
what is
the lifelong also implies that that life
might be coming to an
end here but let's see we jump right to
luffy falling off kaido's moving castle
now
i truly was surprised by this yes it
wouldn't be the first time
luffy lost but the dude had more
experience under his belt such
unwavering confidence and a new hype
technique
but he still got slapped down without
really tiring or worrying kaido too much
kaido doesn't even need to take a break
afterwards
again i think it's fascinating for the
story and i like the fact that one piece
isn't as predictable as some other shows
in that sense
and i like oda's continued respect for
the yonko as well
anyways as luffy continues to fall kaido
remarks that yeah luffy figured out how
to coat his blows and conquerors hockey
but his technique left a lot to be
desired
and that makes complete sense we're so
used to new techniques changing
everything and shown in battles but here
realistically
just because luffy unlocked it it
doesn't mean he perfected it to a
greater extent than kaido and although
some fans don't want to see another gear
it truly seems like it might be
necessary to beat a yonko at this point
kaido straight up laughs at luffy's
attack not even remembering its full
name
there was a possibility that luffy like
big mom
would be saved from the air some people
were saying it could be marco who saves
him before he hits the water or maybe he
saved himself with his stretched out
arms but no oda is making it look as bad
as possible
he is now in the water completely
powerless
obviously the protagonist can't die but
it's going to be
hard for anyone to find him at this
point respect to oda for keeping us on
the edge of our seats
even though we logically know that he
can't kill off his main character
kaido then drops a very important line
saying it seems like luffy couldn't be
joy boy either let me know how you guys
read this line but not only does it lend
to the mystery of joy boy
and reveal more about kaido it teases
the possibility that luffy could be joy
boy
or at least kaido had reason to believe
he could be until he started to believe
that luffy is already as good as dead
now there's already been theories that
luffy is joy boy
although what that would mean exactly is
up for debate but it's cool to see the
possibility escape kaido's lips as well
wow there is so much here to play with
and once everything falls into place
it'll be so fun to go back to these
little moments
and their significance but as i said
kaido is not resting
at all he doesn't need to he's told that
they located momo
and he immediately says he's on his way
yes he's an antagonist and we don't want
him to win
but you gotta appreciate his leadership
here he's
immediately ready to back up his crew
after beating the opponent's
best fighter and he wisely decides to
make an announcement that luffy's been
defeated
and that he's coming to help with the
cleanup psychologically that would
quickly cause the remaining fighters
or at least most of them to lose morale
i like seeing when characters fight
strategically like this
on the psychological level rather than
just on the physical level
but more on that later yamato no longer
with shackles and no longer a prisoner
is fighting off kaido's men as odin
while momo is still reading
and he says he cannot afford to die
after reading something suggesting he
has
even more significance than he thought
something that seemingly even
trumps being the ruler of lano again all
of this
fate and prophecy stuff is really
interesting in one piece like trying to
figure out the secrets of the world
and i like how luffy's quest to become
the freest
corresponds with figuring out that truth
as well
then just when momo seems to get a
massive headache
asking who are you to no one in sight we
jump off to chopper vs queen
now i don't think anyone expected
chopper to actually beat queen even
though the good shots he did get on him
were extremely satisfying
at first it actually looks like chopper
is winning but he's out of breath while
queen is only amused
saying that chopper is pretty short of
breath for someone who's winning
queen even calls him a tanuki pouring
some salt on the wound after chopper
made it known that he's not one
and doesn't appreciate being called one
we see pero sparrow 2
preparing to launch some candy arrows
throughout this fight my eyes are
glued to this candy clown more than ever
our guys need big mom to definitively
betray kaido right now
we get a flashback to caesar clown
pretty much telling chopper to man up
because he's a pirate and a meager three
minutes of gigantification
won't cut it he offered to design a drug
with more added risks but it would
increase the gigantification time to a
whopping 30 minutes pretty cool
but still not enough here to deal with
an all-star in the meantime perospero
just keeps raining down
candy arrows on people but yeah this
doesn't
look good last we saw zoro was out of
commission
luffy is all but dead in the water
chopper is clearly losing and the list
goes on not to mention kaido is now free
to help squash
everyone else unless shanks himself
pulls luffy out of the water now
it looks very grim indeed and i do like
that in shonen because you know they'll
find a way through the dark times
and you'll be able to remember those
times with a sense of pride because you
made it through that kind of situation
it's these kinds of things in shonen
that help motivate people in real life
too even if they do find themselves in a
hard spot at the moment
this is when the announcement is made
and the announcement is so good from a
machiavellian standpoint
everyone is told straw hat luffy the
rebel
with the highest bounty has been
defeated after he was slaughtered
keyword
not beat but slaughtered his corpse was
dropped to the darkest depths of the
night sea the kozuki samurai have failed
the captain has failed and now
kaido is coming to oversee cleanup and
then after painting that quote unquote
you all have absolutely no chance
picture
the announcements add that if the enemy
wants to surrender
and become loyal to kaido they will be
not only spared
but welcomed dude kaido has
clearly read the art of war and the
prince because this is
textbook and insanely well choreographed
obviously are more central characters
like kit
and marco appear more unfazed and sanji
and zorro straight up reject the offer
but it's going to be
much harder for the so-called extras to
not accept such an offer just as with
animals if people are
cornered they're more likely to fight to
the end but if you give them a way out
they're more likely to take it everyone
is told that the victor has already been
decided so
kaido is framing it in a way that
fighting back at this point
seems completely futile momo is still
suffering
needing to tell kinemon something
important but they're interrupted by
odin who as we might suspect
is kanjuro it'll be interesting to see
what momo wants to say
could it have something to do with
sensing luffy and knowing something we
don't yet
both shinobu and momo are tricked when
they see kanjuro
as odin and assume it really is odin and
i gotta say
even though it's pretty obvious that it
is kanjuro and that we just saw
kundro in the previous panel as readers
a part of me was still like
but what if that really is odin i know
it's unlikely but what if
and so i totally understand how kiku
hesitated
and was in turn given a seemingly mortal
wound by
kanjuro then kundra reveals himself
which is probably not the best move
strategically because
it probably makes him easier to stab for
kinemon but it also makes the story more
satisfying when we see kinemon exercise
his revenge on kanjuro rather
than on an odin look-alike we can't be
sure about deaths but right now it
definitely looks like kiku is done for
and kundro already had a mortal wound so
this should really finish him off
kiku says and i quote the lingering snow
is finally melting so i can tell the
dawn is near
wano's dawn will still shine in the
afterlife end quote
really love that the idea that even
those who sacrificed their lives for the
cause like odin
will be able to appreciate the so-called
dawn of wano
kundra then continues to be a
frustrating and interesting villain
saying and i quote someone had to close
the curtain on my life
and you're a perfect fit for that role
after all while i was performing on the
stage
you were my best friend end quote he
says this to kinemon
and by doing so he refuses to repent
right up to the end
rather than being upset about dying he
completely accepts the situation
and so he robs us of a satisfying
revenge
right up to the end he was a terrible
person and a great villain in my view
the dude definitely took shakespeare's
words all the world's a stage
and all the men and women merely players
very seriously
then none other than kaido shows up
where they are and as
momo runs kaido slams kinemon we
definitely can't be sure that kinemon's
done for but the panel makes it look
like kaido straight up smashed through
his entire head
down to the middle of his body momo
cries at seeing this
as people are seemingly dropping like
flies on our side
and we're shown that onigashima looms
over the skies
of mainland wano so things look really
bad now
but we gotta remember the worse it looks
now the more satisfying the eventual
victory will be
and rarely has one piece looked this
bleak
as always this is an amazing story and
this was a surprising and
fascinating chapter not a happy one but
a necessary one for the eventual payoff
let me know your thoughts about this
chapter and where you think the story is
going in the comments below
let me know if you think these
characters are actually dropping like
flies or
if we can't assume anything yet not
until we see the caskets
the samurai were ready to die but it's
still so
sad to think about them actually going
except for kanjuro of course
either way this is all so insane and i
can't wait for the new chapter next week
if you do enjoy these chapter reviews
and want to keep them coming you know
what to do
channel the pirate king within and smash
that like button until it's blue
if you haven't make this the video you
subscribe and hit that notification
bell to turn on all notifications or you
will miss future one piece videos
lastly while you wait for the next
chapter to drop feel free to check out
my growing one piece playlist
that includes videos on all the yonko
warlords supernova
and much more link to that is in the
description
and i especially want to thank the
patron squad over on patreon and here on
youtube who helped make videos like this
one possible first and foremost i want
to thank the patrons of legend the ones
acknowledged by lord tuigo himself alpha
sigma
and red-haired raven and are the
one-tier patrons the ones who stand atop
all clans ingrada pate heffa
al-jatal dr cortman the toasted chi rai
carlo slickback emperor taku spidey life
tinel tungsten tarkis baked buddhist and
cody hebert and
our pro hero tier patrons the one and
only gilgamesh angel cruz
anatoly kazakie cricket xp very gucci
alicia actor bonnie parks
hinokami hinokamian water 10 no ted
sparky 65 joanne garcia fat boy games
metal mama corey mcgowan deadly sane
soul rise slice and dice and pill you
thank you all
so much if you do enjoy our work you can
support more of it by going over to
patreon.com anime uproar and becoming a
patron today for as little as one dollar
if you do so you'll get your name
featured in future videos alongside
these amazing people right here
and you'll even get access to our
private patronly discord where we talk
about anime life and of course
dank memes so check out patreon.com
animeopro link in the description if
you're interested you can also join the
youtube channel by clicking that blue
join button next to subscribe button
that you've hopefully already destroyed
and if you do become a channel member
keep in mind you can find the link to
the discord by going to the community
tab and you'll see secret vip hidden
messages that only channel members can
see
and that's where you'll find the link to
the vip discord
so yeah you can support more content
that way if you prefer whichever way you
support us you can get the same great
benefits
thanks again and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]
foreign